waxed or shaved my entire body and my
eyebrows
actors have to do a lot to prepare for
their roles and when it comes to shaving
their heads
some aren't afraid to go all the way
while you'd think that the biggest stars
in hollywood would be able to use bald
caps and makeup to preserve their
million dollar locks
the bravest of the bunch take the plunge
and just shave it all off and
never look back you said that i would
still be pretty
even if i shaved my head kristen stewart
has never been afraid to make brave
choices for her
film roles i don't care so when it came
to her character in the deep sea
thriller underwater
it was the actress herself who decided
to shave her head
i've been wanting to do this for a long
time just for novel's sake just because
at some point in your life you want to
be able to do that she was playing a
mechanical engineer
and during the shoot had to get in and
out of a complicated and restrictive
dive suit multiple times a day
she said it was just easier to not have
long hair to deal with
as they didn't have to try and get
inside her suit to fix her hair before
calling action
i don't have to put on like a lot of
helmets and stuff so it'll just be
easier for my hairdresser you know
millie bobby brown famously shaved her
head for stranger things when she was
only 12 years old
even though it was for a role the young
actress said it was the most empowering
day of her life
when you get to this stage with your
hair
it's going to get to a stage where you
can't do anything with it
she said she used to hide behind her
hair and thought her beauty and
femininity was connected to her long
locks
but after cutting them all off it made
her want to inspire other girls to not
focus on their outward appearances
but instead what is inside wise words
for such a young person
wow i think letting them be who they
want to be
when karen gillan posted a video of the
day she shaved her head for guardians of
the galaxy
it became clear just how nervous she was
for the big chop
but when given the chance to star in a
life-changing marvel movie
there are no limits to how far most
actors would go for the part
never worked on a film of this scale
before so i didn't really know what to
expect
luckily she has always had a great sense
of humor about it and fortunately she
was able to negotiate to keep her hair
for the rest of the guardians and
avengers movies
you can take risks and that's when the
interesting stuff happens
model turned actress cara delevingne
shaved her head completely bald for her
role in the film
life in a year in which she plays a
woman with cancer who was given one year
to live
i wouldn't have done it without the
opportunity of doing it for a film but
i'm so glad i really recommend it
in order to give the role the respect
she felt it deserved
cara wanted to shave from day one even
though her agents and managers fought
her on
it fortunately she went ahead and did it
and was thrilled with her choice
it's nice to let them free and wild
young wild and free to fully embody her
character gypsy rose in the act
joey king knew she was going to shave
her head for real
because it was in the contract it was
really one of the most special projects
i've ever worked on
before the date that she knew her hair
was coming off she had fun with it by
dyeing her hair blonde
then blue then cutting her bangs even
though it was a huge change at first
she grew to love it and it really
allowed her to totally get lost in the
role
i had read the script of the first
episode and i was like oh my god this is
insane
amandla stenberg shaved her head for the
movie when hands touch
back in 2018 even though the actor isn't
afraid to go there for a part
the experience was very emotional for
amandla i can't even begin to
summarize all of them right before the
cut was scheduled to happen
they had just come out as non-binary and
said that having shorter hair
made them feel more connected to their
gender identity but they also said it
was challenging
because their hair had become a beacon
of self-love and self-acceptance for
many young people who watched them on
screen i felt like my life was
refreshing instagram as opposed to
refreshing life not only did natalie
portman have to shave her head for v for
vendetta
she actually had to do it on camera
portman said that the experience was
really traumatic for her character
but for her it actually felt nice to
throw vanity away during shooting and
focus on the work
well it's sort of like the losing fear
thing that evie goes through is that
fear
is an element of our lives because it
was shaved in the scene as an act of
violence against her character
she was so focused on being in the
moment that she doesn't actually have
any personal memories of it
you tortured me
why when she got the part anne hathaway
became determined to shave her head
to play fantine in les miserables
despite both the director and her
agent's protests
because it happened on camera anne had
absolutely no idea what it was going to
look like afterwards
and was really nervous to look at
herself in the mirror when she finally
worked up the courage
she said she looked like a version of
her little brother which was actually
really comforting
i was really scared to look in the
mirror i it took me about a half an hour
to muster up the courage
charlize theron decided that her now
iconic character furiosa should have a
shaved head for mad max fury road
this was an exciting one for me since
the chop she has become a huge advocate
of the experience
and thinks all women should shave their
heads at least once in their lifetime
theron also said that suddenly she was
20 minutes earlier for everything
because she saved so much time not
having to deal with her hair
which honestly sounds pretty nice very
very long time to figure it out and for
a good six weeks there i didn't think it
was gonna happen for me
earl and the dying girl olivia cook
shaved her head for real
and on camera before it happened she was
way more nervous than excited for the
big moment
but she wanted to do justice to the part
and didn't want to look weird under a
bald cap
so she went for it they filmed the
process to use in the actual film
which was really emotional and turned
out to be a really powerful experience
for both cook
and her co-star thomas mann like her
hair is there on the ground like she
actually went through this
transformation yeah you can't go back
natalie dormer was up for anything when
it came to her casting in the hunger
games
and that included shaving her head in
the book
her character cressida is described as
having a shaved head with tattooed vines
all over it but it never specified
exactly how much of her head was shaved
she was willing to do her entire head
for the part but director frances
lawrence decided on the half-shaved look
because it looked more
capital every single day it was clean
shaven to
uh to put the tattoo the transfer on
every day
jared leto is known for his long
gorgeous locks and for his dramatic
transformations into
any role he takes on since he spares no
expense when preparing
for a roll when it came to cutting his
hair and shaving off his eyebrows for
the joker the actor was all in
once his long brown locks were cut off
his eyebrows were gone
and his hair was dyed green he was
almost unrecognizable
just the way he likes it i fell in love
with the joker i really think
underneath it all he's kind of a
sweetheart hugh jackman might be more
famous for his wolverine updo
but as soon as he hung up his claws and
said goodbye to the role that made him
an international movie star
he wasn't afraid to cut it all off to
play blackbeard and pan
he said that since he is by nature a
lazy guy when it comes to his hair
he was more than happy to get rid of it
after so many years spent maintaining it
for his x-men role
i think it helps create this potentially
limitless world
sia's musical movie music was
controversial for
many reasons so much so that it
overshadowed the fact that kate hudson
shaved her head for her role in it
when the director suggested that hudson
cut her famous blonde locks
the fearless actress just went for it
we're doing the
honors of shaving the head james mcavoy
is no stranger to shaving his head
he first did it for professor x in x-men
first class
and had to do it again for his roles in
split and glass
the first time he did it x-men director
brian singer
actually kept his hair in a bag and
locked it away in a safe in his home
which is a choice i mean it's easy and i
don't have to do anything with it
once you've shaved your head for a role
no one out there can say that you aren't
a committed actor
especially for those who actually did it
on screen like anne hathaway
which one of these bald roles do you
think is the most iconic
we love them all but we are always on
team furiosa